bonjour mathieu sapin copello merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vous
êtes deux dessinateurs à mes côtés pour
parler de vos carnets de campagne c'est
aux éditions dargaud et et seuil petite
présentation rapide copello d'abord
l'origine vous venez du monde du cinéma
mais la bd va prendre de plus en plus de
place dans votre vie en 2017 vous avez
suivi cinq candidats à la présidentielle
vous avez publié des dessins dans le
ring tonnes poste et puis ensuite vous
avez signé palais bourbon les coulisses
de l'assemblée nationale
mathieu sapin difficile de faire la
liste tv dès que vous avez sorti depuis
le début de votre carrière en jeunesse
il ya notamment sardine de l'espace
akissi et puis pour les plus sérieux et
les adultes campagne présidentielle en
2011 et suivi françois hollande ou
encore le château qui raconte les
coulisses de l'elysée en 2014 et puis
avec gérard depardieu 1,5 année gérard
cinq années dans les pattes de deux par
dieu
mathieu c'est vous qui avez eu l'idée de
sortir ce bouquin de faire ce carnet de
campagne ces carnets de campagne quelle
était l'idée de départ de ce livre
l'idée c'est que j'avais suivi la
campagne de 2012 de près dans un seul
candidat et ma frustration à l'époque ça
avait été de ne pas pouvoir suivre un
peu tout le monde et en discutant avec
coco pelo
qui avait un peu en tête de suivre cette
campagne 2022 on s'est dit pourquoi pas
le faire à plusieurs et donc le réunir
une petite équipe une équipe de choc et
suivre chacun un ou deux candidats et
qu'on était l'équipe de maquereau en
général c'est important six dessinateurs
poursuivre une dizaine de candidats à la
présidentielle valérie pécresse ou
encore jean lassalle pour vous un coco
pelo et emmanuel macron pour vous
mathieu sapin faut dire vous avez déjà
quelques contacts au sein de l'elysée
avec vos travaux précédents comment
s'est faite la répartition entre les
différents dessinateurs
c'est des copains donc après c'est
deschamps morgan navarro qui a suivi
marine le pen et eric zemmour je me suis
dit que l'huile et avait pas froid aux
yeux et ça pourrait marcher il a dit ok
et puis il m'a présenté lara qui lui a
suivi mélenchon et et russel et dorothée
de monfreid que je connaissais bien pour
ces travaux jeunesse je savais qu'elle a
envie de passer à des choses de plus
adulte et donc on lui a proposé de
suivre yannick jadot réelles pour elle
ça faisait partie des de ces
dessinateurs qui est un peu des nouveaux
dans cette discipline oui l'idée c'était
vraiment qu'on soit un groupe assez
disparate avec des qualités des cons
dire des compétences différents et pour
qu'on soit le plus varié possible dans
douze de nos approches
c'est ce qu'on peut appeler à dudu du
reportage gonzo il ya les coulisses de
campagne des indiscrétions des off et
puis surtout vous ressenti à vous en
tant que témoin dans les coulisses vous
semblez tous deux assez surpris
d'ailleurs qu'on vous qu'on dise oui
pour ce projet finalement on vous a
ouvert assez facilement les portes
copello oui parce qu'on se représente
tous dans la bande dessinée donc en fait
quand on a faim quand on a froid et là
on le dit et on peut faire un pas de
côté par rapport aux journalistes par
rapport à tout l'écosystème qui entoure
les candidats et ça c'est plutôt
savoureux parce qu'on tombe sur des
situations drôles parfois un peu triste
parfois totalement absurde et on peut
montrer la politique autrement et nous
on a cherché à montrer bas des choses
que personne n'avait vu jusque là dans
cette campagne quoi voilà et pour
l'accueil des candidats ça a été plutôt
facile en fait au début on savait pas
devons partait et puis finalement chaque
dessinateur apprécié aller très très
loin et aller au contact des candidats
ça c'est savoureux bah vous êtes surpris
le bouquin commence notamment dans les
coulisses de la campagne de macron qui
n'est pas officiellement commencé on
vous dit oui tout de suite on vous
reçoit on me donne même des conseils oui
oui mais après c'est vrai que j'avais
fait des précédents albums qui est sûr
ce milieu donc c'est j'ai croisé des
gens dans les équipes qu'ils avaient pu
lire les albums et donc s'en inspirer
tout à l'heure on n'a pas cité aussi
louison qui a suivi l anne hidalgo et ce
qui nous intéressait c'était de suivre
vraiment les petits les candidats
heureux malheureux et c'est vrai que
dans l'album il ya plein de séquences
comme le disait coco pilot qui sont
assez
edit je
pense des séquences of dans des
déplacements à nadine morano sur sur
l'île grecque la visite d'un camp de
migrants
qui qui effectivement tu me tacle un
petit peu parce que bon j'avais un fonds
que c'était une sorte de voyage organisé
et en fait je me suis retrouvé dans
l'île de samos donc où énormément de
migrants venus de turquie viennent donc
pécresse faisait tout un truc au tour de
l'europe de l'immigration là bas je me
suis retrouvé dans un camp de migrants
avec michel barnier nadine morano et
eric ciotti voilà c'était c'était
quelque chose elle a dit mme morano qui
vous taclez puis lors d'eire ya plein de
candidats qui essaie de regarder vos
dessins et malheureusement pour vous
valérie pécresse est tombé sur les
vôtres c'est ça malheureusement oui et
non c'est à dire que j'avais six minutes
dans le train avec elles pour pouvoir la
faire réagir donc c'est impossible dans
une interview classique donc nous on
passe énormément par nos carnets par nos
dessins et moi je décide de lui donner
mes dessins et puis au lieu de lire les
quelques pages que je vais présenter est
fait défiler tout l'ipad avec tout le
pdf et elle et d'autres pages qui sont
moins favorables pour elle et à ce
moment là en fait j'avais senti que
j'avais réussi à percer l'armure c'était
ça qui est intéressant parce que ce
qu'on n'a pas précisé préciser c'est que
on se met en scène dans l'album chacun
de nous se dessine et se représente en
train de discuter avec les candidats à
suivre moi je suis dans un dans l'avion
présidentiel
nous lisons elle est dans les loges avec
anne hidalgo la rai discuter avec
mélenchon est donc sacré vraiment une
bande dessinée très vivante où le
lecteur bas nous suit en fait dans cette
aventure oui vous montrer notamment des
militants qui se donne un peu qui vous
êtes des services de sécurité qui vous
écartez puis on vous laisse passer
finalement ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure vous aviez plus davantage que
les journalistes en fait on avait pas on
n'avait plus de temps aussi parce que
nous l'album sortait après la
présidentielle donc sadc a tranquillisé
aussi les équipes parce qu'il savait que
tout ce qui est hors comme on dit ne
sortirait pas avant le résultat du
deuxième tour donc ce n'était pas tout à
fait les mêmes règles d'ailleurs on
donne pas mal de of pas mal de coulisses
souvent c'est quand même assez cash vous
vous privez pas il ya juste l'art à un
moment qu'il ya un informateur est alors
qu'il griment loup pour montrer
oui bah pour pas à
son informateur sa selle avantages de la
bande dessinée c'est qu'on peut décider
ce qu'on montre ce qu'on montre pas on
peut éventuellement tricher mais nous on
raconte que des choses vraies dans
l'album parfois on maquille un peu
évidemment donne pas forcément les noms
de nos indicateurs ou quoi mais mais
tout est vrai même si ça a l'air parfois
un peu lunaire il ce vrai faux suspense
vous qui avez suivi l'équipe d' emmanuel
macron pendant plusieurs mois et cette
campagne qui s'organise on l'a bien
compris qu'il allait être candidat mais
on ne le dit pas comment est ce que vous
avez vécu ce moment c'est beaucoup de
déception vous allez allez des meetings
vous allez à des déplacements finalement
c'est pas aujourd'hui il faut
recommencer le lendemain oui c'est bah
c'était la déception que que vivaient
tous les tous les journalistes qui
suivent emmanuel macron mai mais c'est
pas une vraie déception parce que moi je
savais qu'il allait se présenter très
tard après je me suis débrouillé pour
infiltrer les équipes en amont et puis
obtenir le maximum d'informations et
c'est intéressant aussi les équipes il
n'y a pas que le candidat serre derrière
son de voir comment se fabrique une
élection avec des éléments de langage
date à mourir et vient de communiquer si
oui comment il comme ils essayent de
scénariser le réel et puis de de
projeter des événements donc en effet je
suis un certain moment dans des réunions
stratégiques où ils vont expliquer
comment ils vont s'y prendre pour
attaquer valérie pécresse pour attaquer
eric zemmour ou autre d'ailleurs du côté
de valérie pécresse est très très
militaire comme organisation et il ya
même des coups de colère à des moments
c'est très cadré c'est le party les
républicains donc c'était très sérieux
voilà elle est partie avec tout le parti
derrière machin dont elle a réuni son
équipe de la région ile de france qui
faisait bloc autour d'elle et puis petit
à petit la campagne était un peu fébrile
et effectivement il ya cette scène du
podcast où elle enregistre un podcast
pour paraître un peu plus sympathique où
pendant une demi heure elle va parler de
son chien voilà donc valérie pécresse
candidate à la présidence de la
république française qui parle de son
chien pendant une demi heure j'ai trouvé
ça un peu lunaire et à la fin et passe
un savon à un de ses collaborateurs
parce que épuisé à bout son chien ne va
pas bien son énorme meeting du zénith
finalement qui était ratée arrive dans
quelques jours et j'assiste à une scène
auxquels les journalistes n'auraient
jamais pu assister vraiment dans
l'intimité du qg de la candidate gars
qui est magique c'est que vous vous ne
suivez deux campagnes donc cette
campagne millimétré de valérie pécresse
et pendant la campagne de jean lassalle
qui partent dans tous les sens on va au
congrès les maires il m'a même pas dans
la salle parce qu'il a occupées acea les
paluches dehors c'est souvent quand est
ce qu'on va manger ou qu'on va boire un
coup c'était une sorte de non candidats
en fait pour résumer sa campagne c'est
vrai que bon ben voilà ses attachés de
presse était fou autour parce que quand
jean lassalle va au resto mais il prend
entrée plat dessert un petit coup de
rouge ensuite il va saluer chaque
personne dans la salle et ensuite ils
passent dans les cuisines pour saluer
chaque cuisinier voilà et pour sa
campagne il avait loué un bus à
impériale comme pour les bleus lors du
mondial avec une terrasse cas on est
parti de son village de lourdios ichère
136 habitants coincés au milieu des
pyrénées et il avait toujours un
camping-car qui le suivait louer exprès
pour qu'ils puissent faire la sieste
après les repas voilà et ça c'est très
sérieux
chacun devait réaliser une quarantaine
de pages tout ça est sorti très très
vite le but était de 2-2 de publier ses
carnets de campagne juste après le
résultat de la présidentielle comment
est ce qu'on fait pour pour sélectionner
en télé quand on fait un reportage c'est
difficile de ce qu'on appelle des
rochers de même près très vite la
contrainte vous avez six dessinateurs
différents des candidats différents
beaucoup de planches vous avez dû
travailler dans l'urgence j'imagine oui
dans l'urgence puis c'est surtout
progressif c'est dire que la pression
monte de plus en plus plus on se
rapproche de l'échéance alors nous on
avait un fil de discussion et on se
tenait à jour en permanence de savoir
moi moi je vais là il y avait morgan
navarro qui était à dunkerque avec
marine le pen en même temps
dorothée
qui était à rouen et donc on savait en
permanence ceux qu'on suivait ce qu'on
faisait et on devait en effet réalisé
les pages au fur et à mesure et dans une
certaine urgence mais dans la bonne
humeur quand même parce qu'on l'a pas
dit mais c'est quand même une bd assez
drôle je pense parce que on raconte
aussi beaucoup nous nous nous échangeons
nos échanges nous engueule nos
hésitations nos galères et c'est plus
l'album en fait tu racontes plus là
l'espèce davanture baroque de six
auteurs de bandes dessinées qui essaye
de suivre la campagne et qu'il y arrive
tant bien que mal et ce qui est
formidable c'est qu'à la fin on a eu
heureusement quand même des accès
vraiment de de première main
je sais pas si on peut dire que morgan
navarro a quand même était enfin moi je
spoile en mai chez jean marie le pen au
moment du deuxième tour fait des choses
comme ça qui sont complètement
improbable l'ascenseur d'ailleurs c'est
magique parce qu'une certaine naïveté
par exemple chez dorothée de monfreid d'
qui suit yannick jadot ou encore louison
il ya vraiment les coulisses où elle
croit par exemple que le meeting va
durer deux heures alors qu'on attend les
candidats les candidates pendant quatre
heures elles ratent leur train ils ont
les coups de fil à la maison elle pense
avoir fini le couvrir un meeting que la
journée est terminée puis en fait faut
recommencer derrière pas a été de 2,2
marché de cavale et c'est passionnant
c'est très très drôle
il ya un petit détail dans la rédaction
de tout ça et dans les dessins est ce
que les masques ça vous a gêné parce que
c'est une véritable contrainte j'ai la
réaction quand même dans dessins on est
quand même en pleine pandémie de kobe 19
tout le monde est masquée sauf que vous
votre boulot c'est de dessiner les
candidats et surtout leur staff oui moi
ça m'a gêné un peu parce que le début je
me disais bon ben voilà on va jamais
reconnaître valérie pécresse michel
barnier nadine morano et c'est donc
c'est de voir à travers des scènes en
extérieur ce que je pouvais faire quand
ils enlevaient les masques mais on
essaie de respecter quand même quoi
qu'il arrive le port du masque ou non et
ça montre aussi beaucoup de choses dans
les
différentes campagnes qui se passait
c'était que chez zemmour ou chez le pen
y avait très peu de masques par exemple
chez les républicains énormément donc au
début de l'album en plus on voit tout le
monde masqué et petit à petit le
connaître s'efface au profit de la
guerre en ukraine et les masques tombent
et à ce moment là on peut redessiner
correcteur de personnages oui et et puis
c'est vrai que battu parler de la guerre
en ukraine c'est ça qu'il ya pour moi
tout vraiment rebattu les cartes ouais
c'est le point de bascule alors
comme tout le monde on a été
complètement saisi par ce moment et est
d'assister aussi ce moment où la gare en
ukraine éclaté on voit que les équipes
sont pas prêtes et préparé du tout et
que ils savent pas trop comment ils vont
devoir réagir et quel impact ça va avoir
sur la campagne donc aujourd'hui
malheureusement s'y habituer ça fait
partie de l'actualité mais sur le moment
rappelez vous fin c'était vraiment il ya
de la sidération les gens se demandaient
qu'est ce qui va se passer là dans l'est
dans les 24 heures ouais on sent dans
votre dans votre livre à cette rumeur
qui monte vous entendez parler d'ukraine
petit à petit et puis là le truc explosé
prend le pas sur sur cette campagne une
dernière question qu'est ce que vous
faites pour les législatives on se
repose ouais parce que faire six mois de
campagne on est sortis totalement sécher
de la rive parce qu'on devait dessiner
en même temps et c'est enfin c'était
quand même un sacré rythme et on peut
dire qu'il ya quand même quelques uns de
nos collaborateurs qui ont pris le virus
est qui qui vont suivre notamment
l'aventuré du ps mais c'est passionnant
s'appelle carnet de campagne ccc chez
dargaud et et seuls ses sorties tout de
suite après l'élection
présidentielle merci beaucoup mathieu
sapin merci beaucoup comeau pelo d'avoir
accepté notre invitation pour le nous
présenter ce livre que je conseille très
fortement c'est très drôle et ça permet
d'avoir un autre regard sur sur cette
campagne pour l'élection présidentielle
merci d'être venus chez nous merci merci
à vous d'avoir choisi france 24